[Music]
uh
hi hi hello
it's me um it's hot um look i'm i'm
sorry to interrupt
um i just i i um i've noticed that in
these
long superhero montages loki tends to
get
you know a bit left out even though
arguably he's incredibly heroic
himself you know cunning charming
i could go on but but but maybe why
don't i just
prove it to you wednesdays are the new
[Music]
fridays
i know what this place is
[Music]
the timekeepers have built quite the
circus
and i see the clowns are playing their
parts to perfection
big metaphor guy i love it makes you
sound super smart
i am smart i know okay okay
please sign to verify this is everything
you've ever said this is absurd
sign this too
we protect the proper flow of time
you picked up the tesseract breaking
reality
i want you to help us fix it
why me i need your unique low-key
perspective
do i get a weapon yeah
you really believe in this low-key
variant
luckily he believes in himself enough
for the both of us
[Music]
it is adorable that you think you could
possibly
manipulate me
i'm 10 steps ahead of you
you're not big on trust are you
you can trust me okay i've studied
almost every moment of your entire life
you've literally stabbed people in the
back like 50 times
never do it again
you